لا أعلم أن اللاعبين قد لمسوه
الكثير من الناس من المغرب أيضا ولكن
هذه هي القضايا الاجتماعية، كما تعلمون هناك
الناس طفل حسنا أعتقد ذلك
اليوم لا ينبغي لنا أن نفعل أكثر من ذلك
18 19 طفل عمره ربما 20 أو نعم
يبلغ من العمر 25 عامًا، وهو طفل، وسيفعل ذلك أيضًا
نتعلم من هذا الموضوع أن الشبكات الآن
الاجتماعية هناك أطفال الذين فقدوا
في بعض الأحيان توجد عنصرية في الحياة ولكني
أعتقد أن العنصرية أكثر اجتماعية من
بقي من الولد الصالح الذي سوف يتعلم
لا أريد أن أطيل الموضوع بعد الآن
لأنه فتى لديه حياة
بعد ذلك لا أريد أن أقتله فنحن كذلك
المسلمين وفي منطقتنا
لقد تعلمنا أن نسامح لذلك دعونا
سامح هذا الطفل الذي يتعلم من هذا
الموضوع وأنه يبقى وربما سيعطي
مثال للآخرين أننا شعب
متواضع كما تعلمون وهو موضوع امتد من
المسلمين لا يوجد هذا الأفضل
مثال يمكننا أن نظهر ونغفر
سأخبر هذا الطفل أنه صنع واحدة
نقص والتعلم من ذلك ونرى ما
ما رأيك في المسلمين ليست جيدة
أن نغفر ونمضي قدما